transformational experiences or
experiences of catharsis usually occur
when we surrender when we finally let go
when we let our guard down long enough
for something to happen something
unexpected some new realization to
transpire now most of the time human
beings we're guarded right we are the
descendants of the most hyper vigilant
humans in our past those that were on
guard survived those that were chilled
out got eaten so there is a reason where
we are a collective mass of control
freaks nowadays so even though we know
that all the good stuff happens when you
let your guard down we cannot help but
be on guard we got a plan we got to
survive we got a pre assess look I get
it
and so again the bumper sticker becomes
this whole thing of like dude you just
gotta surrender you're just gonna let go
and you just gotta like dive in and the
thing is like in love you don't dive
into love you fall in love and so I
suppose the the secret to letting go
lies in staging experiences in which you
forget to remember to be on guard
experiences that are enthralling enough
that hijack your attention enough that
they eclipse the monkey mind the mind
that is on guard the autobiographical
narrative that's trying to make sense of
what's happening that's trying to cohere
what is happening see what happens is
when you finally slip into the zone when
you fall into the forever box when you
all of a sudden you find yourself there
you didn't feel it happening you didn't
say okay now I'm gonna surrender you
know what happens is it almost became
like subconscious there was a kind of
switch there was a kind of pivot and so
you know it is said that today we live
in the experience economy everybody's
practicing mindfulness medication
mindfulness meditation going on yoga
retreats trying to plug into the eternal
now I get it look we're monetizing and
commoditizing experiences that are
transformational everybody wants to go
to Burning Man and experience renewal
and rebirth I get it but I guess the set
of best practices
the techniques of ecstasy the the the
four forces of ecstasy the psychology
technology neurobiology and pharmacology
that we need apply to pre pattern these
transformational experiences have to
hold in mind have to bring to the
situation the fact that most of us are
gonna be on guard and unless we
lubricate people enough to slip stream
into the now to let their guard down
without realizing they're letting their
guard down then no transformation will
occur I was recently on safari in Africa
before I knew it I'm on the back of a
jeep no ceiling and I'm exposed to the
elements
I felt instinctually alive I felt
present in ways I never felt present
before now I didn't say oh I'm about to
let go I was just in an experience
immersive enough that I didn't have time
to remember to let my guard down or keep
my guard up I was just there I was just
in it Terence Mckenna the psychedelic
philosopher says you become what you
behold right in psychedelic circles the
heuristics set and setting means that
the environment you're in will bleed
into your trance will bleed into your
experience when you're immersed in the
present you're in a liminal space you're
here but you're also in your head is the
space between dreams and reality it's a
fusion of cognition and dream and so
what you have to realize is that the
environment matters the environment cues
you right the the American psychologist
William James says your experience is
what you attend to author David linson
says the goal is heightened stewardship
of internal life he cites the 1965
phrase of dismissal get out of my movie
which reflects this heightened
stewardship of internal life what is
what is disliked must be avoided and
what is enjoyed can be enjoyed with
contemplative exactitude and so at the
end of the day my friends in the age of
experience which were training the
technical material of subjectivity
itself let us remember my friends let us
remember the artistry the techniques the
stage design
management of attention and awareness is
where the treasure lies is where the
magic lives so that's my take on
experience design in the new economy
you